how does it work because all of us as
you can tell i'm here in an abandoned
theater you look too
i think you broke in i'm in an abandoned
theater you broke into a movie we both
broke into these theaters to meet each
other
for this illicit tryst uh i'm curious
i know what it's like working during
covid it is very strange
but it's pretty simple i talk to you on
zoom i do some comedy on zoom
we're okay how do you do this show
during covid i mean you're constantly
surrounded
by zombie extras people dressed as
zombies have they all been tested
yeah they've been very compliant
actually the zombies they've been
uh all negative for covet positive still
for
zombies but they're really
it is just a trip too because everybody
when this all started there like
lauren will know what to do she's been
she's lived through a zombie apocalypse
for 10 years and and i'd love to say
that everybody was joking i really think
and i said i'm going on amazon and
buying bottled water just like the rest
of you
yes i know it's so funny that i hadn't
thought of this beforehand
but uh your show really is about the
spreading of this virus
and uh people turning into zombies it
makes
covid look just downright boring um
but it's so weird to me that you have
all these people
dressed up hundreds of extras dressed up
like zombies who've caught this virus
and then they all have to get nasal
swabs to test before they can shoot a
scene
okay you're a zombie but you're you
don't have covid so
you can come on through um
yeah i know you're probably aware that i
i got to
uh to become friendly with your
former co-star my good friend yes uh
stephen young
and uh he and i had a great trip
uh to korea together and uh
i got to see up close what a terrific
guy he is
and um we had this really nice
experience but you guys
made it very special for him when he was
leaving the show
you you went to a lot of trouble you and
your cast
mates went to a lot of trouble to sort
of make it an occasion
yeah well it's no trouble it's it's
was the moment that i think we are still
that was still the hottest goodbye we've
ever had on the show i won't
even talk about it too much because it's
interesting because his son being back
his son his his on-screen son has
brought up so many memories for
everybody of steven being here yeah
and uh you know we do these like death
dinners for everybody so we'll have sort
of like a civilized
thing and everybody will give nice
speeches and we knew for stephen and
from michael cudlets who left in the
same episode we wanted to do something
extra special
um and as you guys know from your k-pop
day is you and stephen
steven and i did shoot i'll tell the
viewers that don't know
steven and i did shoot a k-pop video
together it took about 24 hours to shoot
it nearly killed us
um and uh but i know that that that man
loves to he loves to dance he loves to
sing
he's really into it yeah he is really
into it and
we basically got together and all the
girls sort of thought
it might have been deny's idea actually
and we just thought what's the best way
that we can sort of send these guys off
and so
we had a party at our producer's house
and we all disappeared to go and get our
costumes on
and learn like the final pieces of our
absolutely atrocious dance routine
to slowly re-enter the house one by one
verse by verse to perform backstreet
boys i want it that way
and stephen was actually crying we were
dressed up as
michael cudless's character with orange
mustaches and orange
wig i have the picture i have the
picture right here
i have you guys someone took a picture
and i've never seen
this video you're not allowed to show
the video we're not yeah you're not
allowed to show the video
and uh but i thought this was a rare
photo behind the scenes of you guys
saying goodbye
to steven uh and his character glenn and
you're all dressed as backstreet boys
but you've added
um you've added orange mustaches which
is a beautiful
orange mustache just so we're abraham
and that that t-shirt is a photo that
stephen took his favorite
zombie on the show and it's this zombie
just like sparking a cigarette and
smoking which is one of the best things
on
on our set it's like seeing a zombie in
a dr pepper
or zombie vaping or just like the most
random things that they'll do
yeah i love that i love that yeah yeah
you guys have had such adventures you
and stephen i mean you're
you're you're spa what did you do yeah
we went to a spa together
we were we were uh we were naked
together at a spa a wee spa
here in los angeles and um he took me
and uh he said you're going to have an
experience
he took me to the spa and he also he's
that's the night he stole my heart
and uh we had a really intense time that
was before we went to korea together so
that's how it starts when men go
to a spa together and they spend some
time with each other's bodies
it ends up with them traveling around
the world together
let's take this to the next level please
yes
i'm just glad that he was okay with it
because